you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome I got have your mic in
front of you I need the mic you are
about to play no man's sky next on Xbox
one X it's here it is let's cut the
gameplay just real quick get right into
it although you're safe so this is very
exciting Jake we've been playing this
game this morning it came out Xbox first
holy God so much has changed mm-hmm like
more into your game as we speak
so right now you just see me doing it
doing a little sit down emote here I
mean yeah where to begin there so much
has changed so you and I played just
like kind of it's it is at its core very
much the same game so there's still that
intro where you need to fix up your
generic ass ship here you go to the
space station you there's the awakenings
quest line that they added in the last
update so all that's there that means
elements though all that being said all
that's the probably one of the biggest
things carbon is probably the only one
that looks familiar every other element
and not just the name of the element but
like what their functions are have been
just completely scrapped not only that
but like you're like fair right here you
have to run ferrite dust through like a
refinery almost like like in Minecraft
well they added all those systems in
order to to to get pure ferrite which
you then use for variety of things I
believe it's a component - what is it
for it's like a components I actually
it's like plutonium where you need it to
like launch in your spaceship so I'm in
your game easy so you're in my game up
but I'm on the planet you're I'll meet
you in the Space Station okay cool
and I'll just continue showing around so
that's that's one thing is like all
again all these elements have been
changed now you get obviously
third-person you get awesome some of
these animations are really cool that's
classic
thumbs up sit down help if you're
choking out like I can't breathe
and then there's a pretty cool jump
they're very like cartoonish almost like
I know they remind me of like over
watching away as far as like the emotion
of it yeah yeah and like sit down anyway
so that's pretty sweet
so yeah third person let's see here I
can swap to first show you how to do
first person if you wanted to go back
like on PC I'd probably go first person
here but you can do third person ship as
well a third person I'm coming around -
right like it's it's pretty cool
especially with the controller if that's
how you're gonna play I'm sure there are
a bunch of questions in chat we're
playing on xbox one X both of us Jake's
arriving in a second you might play a
little chat delay but I think we're good
now so it we may have missed a question
so is there only four player co-op or is
there versus with more players so I
think you can run into other players we
haven't run into any other but there's
four player co-op I'm about to meet Rob
at the space station actually let's see
if I can get you shown up so like it
looks so good that's one thing it's hard
for you guys watching on the stream
because of just bitrate and compression
but like it looks really great like if
if you are familiar with the game like
this was very generic as far as textures
go like now it's got a whole bunch of
you know vents and decals and stuff so
Jake's gonna arrive in a second yeah
being followed by a drunk by sentinels
so I have to wait until they're not
messing with me and then I can okay cool
I'll be sure to zoom in on when you're
on you when you arrive one of the
coolest things that we were talking
about this morning is that we've had on
Xbox at least like no network problems
like he joined a game very easily like
right in the beginning like if you
remember you oh wow you're really gonna
attack that it's it's I pissed on the
Sentinel I didn't think they'd follow me
this this what I was saying is like then
the app network has been really great
like Jake and I once he joined no
network problems he was always around
following me and I was following him
every bit of the way
oh man I want to [ __ ] even like the
animations of these guys look more
pronounced like not so like generic
those guys giving me some trouble okay
oh well then it's really cool so I'll
just show off like the tower area I'm
calling it the tower it's not official
but much is this there's been way too
much obviously yeah anyways so we're
kind of stolen here I'm gonna show off
this area so this is new obviously if
you guys remember like it just used to
be just a door and every space station
looked exactly the same now it's like
almost like a market communal hub with
all your same like NPCs like here's like
the Galactic terminal you can like you
know trade stuff yeah this dude I don't
know what he does understand his
language so yeah we're starting a new
save because obviously just launched
today on Xbox one we were gonna play if
you remember those just those of you
guys joining from yesterday we played on
PC yesterday and we were hoping to play
on PC but we decided to do Xbox because
the update was not out yet and funny
enough it just hit on PC so we it's one
of the reasons why we were delayed on
the stream is that we're gonna come back
to PC a little bit later in the stream
just do a swap just to see like our
previous saves and see to see what they
did as far as the changes man they're
sending reinforcements after you are
getting into it you go you go you can't
you can't change on post jump so here's
your here's where you would get upgrades
I believe with the Nana Knights nanites
there's a technology merchant Jake
started a war Jake on it did Jake is
yours I'm seeing like combat ships that
I've never seen before in this game yeah
my feets probably bit more interesting
well actually not right now cuz I'm just
flying like they're still after me this
is that I don't remember them being this
aggressive before yeah that's weird
to buy it oh man I don't know I I would
say yes but I really like I like the
game when it came out you know and so
did you mm-hmm if you didn't like the
game when it came out like maybe it is
it's not full price on Xbox it's $50 and
it is on sale now on PSN it was $60 I
think earlier but when the update
dropped it is now like 26 if you have
PlayStation Plus I believe because a
friend sent me he was asking if he
should buy it because it was super cheap
on PSN not super cheap but you know so
let's show off the customization so this
was real fun and exciting today and when
we see Jake I'll show you what it looks
like if I ever get there if we ever get
there the customization it's like super
intense uh in a in the best way possible
look there's a lot going on so you start
off as like the anomaly race just
generic kind of human esque
looking guys so there are presets here
lots of questions here okay yeah I'll
just go through this oh man they've been
buried what's the point of this game
depends there's a story you can follow
get to the center the universe or you
can follow the Atlas path or you just
kind of do whatever you want like
upgrade build a base make it as good as
you can
yes it is on PC the the patch is not
well actually is the patch we don't know
if the patches out yet right
all right apparently it is it is a
defeat so we're gonna um we're gonna
come back to the PC a little bit later
in the stream we just wanted to show off
kind of like you know the coal office
off Wow look at dude look at this guy
have you seen these presets woah oh is
that one of those like a mutant catfish
it looks like a Pink Panther go back
that's the Pink Panther Panther
this reminds me is out downloading now
in Europe alright look at that is that
captain hot Rob that's whoa my gosh
that's great that last one this one No
all right that one oh my god wait until
you wait I can't wait til chatzi's my
character they're gonna love them I
already have the voice down I'll wait
I'll wait to do the voice until yeah
okay
get there and I can't wait so yeah you
can do tons of you know color schemes
here like I am way past or cherry planet
why are they still following me this is
definitely new goop says what up Bros
what's up Google what up guy look at
this
alright so I'm gonna go with classic
here stormtrooper stormtrooper I have
200 hours saved and I don't want to lose
my progress especially more should be
okay you should be okay things are gonna
look very different though and I don't
know if your base will still be intact I
don't know kind of reminds me of like V
that is actually we'll look at your safe
later yeah well look at my safe later on
PC I have like a safe with like 20 hours
on it so the and some base building so
you can get idea of that and see how it
transfers over it's kind of reminds me
of like the the near robots you know
yeah again we're just waiting on Jake
here to show up
oh you're close all right don't go in
yet don't go in yet I'm all going I
won't go ahead oh I was gonna just jump
in front of you guys you know I wanted I
want to see this alright alright the
intro oh I'm still being shot I can't
stop dude what I see you oh yeah they
followed me all the way just start the
game we have started the game what do
you what more do you want from us oh
that's pretty cool huh
alright you're right you ready for my
voice of my character mm-hmm all right
[Music]
stay still okay look mom I look so good
can you do can you do first person is
there a hi oh good is there a height
difference do first person I know it's
the same I was hoping your eye level
with me I'm not all right then
oh yeah I am I in your eye level huh
maybe that'll be like because they said
they're gonna do updates every week
maybe yeah apparently weekly updates all
right so let's let's start moving right
yeah I want us off this station I think
I think that's a good idea we've been
here for a while huh I'm just gonna take
one of these to go with the storm
trooper I call it day all right
this has multiplayer yes as of today it
does you're looking at it all right Jake
let's get out of here we have the same
ship because we just started a new save
unfortunately but it is what it is all
right I'll follow you okay rather than
trying to stake we'll try to stay close
but let's find a planet first actually
do you want to go to this objective this
mission objective yeah because I think
if we follow this mission objective it
will our stay still for one second okay
so this is what I was trying to show so
you want when you're flying with people
you want to like tag them so I feel like
you you will always be on my HUD because
you can't get lost all right so I'm
gonna get a little coaster do on all
right we'll go to the signal source blow
something up please all you just ran
into me it doesn't hurt me I'm going I'm
going for the red thing all right
I can't there we go hyperdrive
I think you're like right next Ayane
yeah I think we're pretty close so a
third person looks pretty cool elements
have been redone so hopefully not that
many yet elements have been redone there
are also like wing wing ring planets
which is pretty cool we'll take a look
at one of those later I think oh I miss
you so what's what do we got going on
here yes it is live on ps4 yeah we're
just gonna go to signal source because I
think it'll get us a new work drive so
we can head to a new new a thing or I'll
have us build one I wish you could
switch views away a little easier it's a
little like yeah I wish it was like you
just click a button yeah here let me
land first because it's kind of neat
when you uh when you see me laying down
yeah like you kick up a lot of dirt when
you fly by and stuff it's kind of cool
looks so much better yeah it does look a
lot better it looks so much better yeah
ah
oh I landed far away and one of the best
things I landed on the objective you
landed far away yeah I wanted a little
bit of intro well they what they added
or left in was the like kind of like the
glitch if you melee and do the jetpack
you get like a running burst jump they
kind of love that image is nice I'm
getting eaten up here so again all the
elements are changed it's crazy like
Samian theme IAM is oxygen now and they
serve different purposes I feel like
yeah D hydrogen are dihydrogen excuse me
o terrain manipulator carbon nanotubes
hydrogen dihydrogen jelly you got photo
mode that's still here Oh interesting
enough it you move but I don't oh my God
look at your yeah you move my camera
oh cool so what's going on here we fixed
this yeah we have to gotta make some
nanite tubes I need some carbon for that
I didn't think I would dig the third
person on foot so much but it's really
cool yeah I'm like right here it's it's
cool like the are there new or better
creatures now I mean there were millions
of creatures to begin with right but
they've been like fixed I think they're
not as like janky as they used to be
yeah like on our we both started the
same say at the same time and like did
that again that intro tutorial one thing
that I felt like I noticed was that in
the before this update oh the animals
kind of act is very very much
independently like they just like walk
around do their own thing like we saw
probably like a dozen animals and they
were all moving together herd yeah they
do know they do move in Hertz Park I got
it yeah terrain manipulation because
we're gonna make a base here is what it
wants us to do oh we're starting off
soon huh there so it says it wants us to
build the base computer but in order to
do that we need a trained ammonium
manipulator
look at my jank ass where's the hundred
spaceship Battle Royale who's walk it's
pretty cool all right so let's how we
find this thing or build it what do we
need again so it's a multi-tool almost
all right it's the terrain manipulator
okay dihydrogen dihydrogen jelly
scan here's some over here a whole bunch
we just need okay cool whoops can you
text chat and multiplayer or is it only
voice chat maybe PC it's different but
it seems like on Xbox it is just voice
chat although actually we haven't even
tested voice chat to be honest because
where we've been next to each other next
to each other
sorry if I miss a question it's because
I'm trying to do multiple things at once
here
yeah just keep dropping it keep
broadening keep looking
put a queue in front of it as well yeah
helps
all right let's should be enough so
let's make some jelly mmm can we eat
this jelly like even some of this tech
like there's so much new stuff like yeah
you see this oxygen recycler I don't
know what is that just I mean I suppose
that's just like I want to see a battle
you to fight so you can't hurt each
other you can shoot me if you want okay
I won't read this person's name but he
says what basically did they add gosh
so the rundown you go you do it you can
create your own character now there's
multiplayer you can build bases anywhere
they redid all of the elements and what
ones you need in order to survive etc
those are probably the big ones there's
a ton of little changes like the that
the space stations have been redone are
you guys playing on xbox one X is there
a difference in performance so we were
both playing on xbox one X but you
played on the regular I played on
regular and I didn't have any problems
with as far as like framerate it did
look better on yours no doubt yeah these
are both X though not 4k obviously and
it looks really great I mean it's you
know if it looks good for you guys it
really does look much better here just
do the compression and the bitrate we
have going with a stream okay so I think
don't have enough stuff here yeah so
activity aspirin manipulator and use the
visor and compass to locate resource
spots of eating copper that's a weak oh
is it showing us buried treasure no II
need copper but is this what it's
alluding to because that's how you would
I think this is how you would do it yeah
but I don't think we're gonna find I
need to think
[Music]
whoa whoa I just went flying some
personal Jesus scare me it was insane
are there graphical changes yes
graphically the game was a lot better
all around
I haven't played on ps4 though to be
fair but this looks better than it when
it did on PC and I was playing on PC
before the update so I'm curious how pcs
gonna look with you yeah definitely okay
cop around yeah we need some copper oh
that's dune buggy find carbon I'll come
to you I guess what is this what do we
have here for Tex cube jetpack power
surge detected I don't know what that is
well I suppose we can just start digging
see if I find anything did he give any
hints where do you find this game like a
dig it looks like for copper I don't
know if this is maybe I found copper
before when our first planet that we
started in
also notice the scanner takes longer now
I bet it because it wants you to level
it up oh look at dude no no so I'm not
paying attention to the what's on like
damn screen do the scanner has an
overhaul so like it'll show you deposits
so looking for deposit all right so
there's one here that's a git that's far
not as far as everyone that's good yeah
we can why we have we have spaceships we
have the technology all right Agda do
you see it as well yep I see it dope
I'll meet you there
there's AI that will kill you uh I mean
there there's a the bots the the
sentinels my life support systems are
failing I wasn't even that far away yeah
it didn't look that far where's
commander shepard it's good question
that's a good one
I like that all right we're here
now light Keats turning off yo when dis
witnesses come out again I got good news
for you
it's a it's out on everything - we were
a little worried that PC may not make it
today but what race you playing rob is
playing unknown right or an AR anomaly
yeah which is like basically all this
dude's pissed so do you notice they have
like threat indicator like HUD marks
like it'll show you throw out there
you're like oh yeah it'll show you if I
guess threaten indicator is what you
could call that but they don't like it
when I do this they don't like it when i
touch their stuff oh I don't have a gun
you have a gun no I don't have a gun
either great I can hit it with the
mining beam it hardly does anything that
I've tried it doesn't do much see your
laser so easy damage so we have she
craft this I have a bolt caster yeah but
I don't know where to find chromatic
metal
crafting empty slots so with the craft
bullets now oh my god that's changed
i've almost killed this thing rob come
help me oh I can craft bullets okay I'll
help you a second yeah but you don't
have anything to shoot the ball its Witt
yes I do my man you do yeah [ __ ] work oh
you've got it oh I got to put it in the
goddamn gun reload Oh where's that this
is that it just hit X is it good now I
mean I think it's good I liked it when
it came out though it's better yeah it's
better all right well I dealt with it
with my mining beam no help from you
sorry oh that now it goes that was weird
wasn't the flame wasn't working here's
another one
what's up wow this even this doesn't do
much wow there guys
what's this oh you need the terrain
manipulator that get copper yeah I
realize that that's cool is this a copy
of destiny uh-oh
I'm pissing him off Rob I'm not looking
back though I'm just I'm just digging is
it me or is a letter capital question a
little more difficult I feel like I feel
like sentinels are a little more pissed
off in this update well it depends on
the planet - yeah I'm - a planet where
they are they don't like us button into
their business he sees me sentinels are
searching I'm hidden from them did you
get enough copper give me stuff later
with not gonna give you any of my copper
oh I thought you would everybody's got
enough copper yeah I got 86 all right
can you just track this guy yeah oh my
god little hole there oh my god can you
leave me alone dude hmm come distract
these guys oh I gotta get that guy this
copper first
why isn't it oh my god oh you have to
use the tro that's what you're saying
you really do have to use it yeah oh man
we are pissing them off I'm just gonna
run how much copper do we need I don't
know why don't we just come back up
they're searching for me I'm gonna hide
how much better does it feel already it
feels a lot better okay well we're
crafting again I forget what are we
doing let me check the mission log
establish base collect chromatic metal
chromatic do we have to is that
something that the user refining before
I think so all right
why is your screen red on the sides it's
because we're in a we're in a hot planet
oh no I don't have any fuel see what I
can do
I need a lot
I can see the action yeah they're
shooting yeah alright thanks for other
I'll see if I can help you
I have rockets
that's oh I need where is he clear how
it is on PC I think I saw it was like
six gigs almost seven gigs maybe I don't
know what it was on Xbox cuz we just
downloaded the game and it was like
eight gigs I think total but that was
the game - warning urgent they are after
me where's our base whatever you want to
call it we're supposed to shoot him I
don't know where they are
for the sentinels oh there we go
oh there the dog ones now oh yeah I know
I'm I'm I'm uh not something we fired
I'm in trouble
when you find someone do you see orbs do
you see them you see them now we need a
lot more copper well I'm getting away
from here
all right I'm let's just go to another
deposit I don't even want our base to be
on this stupid planet anyone else
playing sex should get off this planet
okay the only thing is is don't go to
orbit until you the Sentinels are done
searching for you because then it's
impossible to warp jump does the update
make the game feel more alive uh yes and
no I mean I think having a buddy with
you helps a lot and like the the actual
stations feel a little bit more alive
this feels lonely but it's still like
you can pretty much avoid everyone if
you want what do you need
launch fuel you need metal plate ting
yep metal plating which is NaN what they
call it ferrite all right yes usually
shoot rocks thanks for answering no
problem yeah like we said before we're
both playing right now so it's really
hard to watch chat we're definitely
doing it we'll try to answer your
questions but if we don't get to it it's
not because we don't like you because
we're 49 emotes do a dance okay I'll
show you the emotes here dead game
question mark I don't think so thumbs
ups pretty classic no uh help I'm
choking all right I am no longer wanted
by the Sentinel so maybe we can go to
another planet and try to establish a
base
this one's really long oh look it's you
confirmed team kill right there you can
kill me if he wants but he won't do that
right right ever see what else we got
here over here come here
and then this when you encounter people
at random I don't know it might be worth
checking the patch notes for that
I have not we have not rained any people
at random but like so here's game is so
huge that I I think the chances are very
very so here's what I saw on Reddit and
I finally found a little interesting
because so we presumably landed in a
system that no one has ever finished
will you stop I'm gonna shoot down this
[Music]
now I won't do it anyways I someone I
think had named unless you named it was
like JA or something I don't know who's
clearly someone had named it apparently
you can join random people so some guy
and really was saying that he to turn
off that function because someone joined
his game that he was starting fresh and
wanted to basically name everything
himself
something joined his game and he like
went away for two seconds and came back
and everything was named because someone
joined in on him and and did all the
work for him so you may want to turn
that off
if you wanted to do some things on your
own for a time being and then turn it on
if you wanted to like at a later point
join other people yeah so so I guess you
can join random people through the
through the matchmaking at the beginning
so I don't know if I can necessary just
run into random people I should be good
now
just good Robin and I should probably
make another one or taking way too long
this game is still tough d hydrogen do
you know get the planet Rover from the
start and know it doesn't seem like it
it shows it like it's grayed out which
is interesting like but previously you
had to find the blueprint to even like
see it table it wants to know if this is
prerecorded this is not pre-recorded if
it seems that way it might be because
we're not answering questions as quickly
as you might like is it easy to link up
with friends actually it's very easy I
think you right when it starts and says
you can play with friends you can play
by yourself and if you if you have a
friend playing you can join them right
there if they have enough space and then
you join in their game it can be tough
to find them like it's easy to lose this
little tag which Rob probably can't see
maybe if I fly over Robbie can see it
yeah that was a tag right there I hit
about six different trees do you need
really good Wi-Fi for this I don't know
oh no I did initiate landing sequence
I saw that such a such a goofball you go
yeah all these are different is it
cross-platform ah I don't think so dude
it lets go wrong I know I'm taking a
while come on Charlie no all right let's
see if I have enough for here jean-marie
said find people you can shoot them and
steal their gear he did say this hey Rob
come back yeah I don't have much and
neither do you
alright oh I think I see more copy right
over here okay I'll go land there I'll
reach it's pretty close how do you get
blueprints for the planet Rover please I
don't know if it's like the other the
old ones you just had to do or if it's
like the previous update you had to you
had to build a pad for them
all right I kick up a lot of dust there
that's cool
oh really nailed that landing tonight a
little bit of framerate drop there how's
the performance fps Oh Matt oh damn
we need a decent amount of copper here
huh
yeah it seems like that like I want to
say there's a lot more there there are a
few more steps in order to do what we're
more basic operations like you know
putting plutonium into your ship it's
not as you know one to like mine it put
it in as you saw earlier you have to
make sheets and you have to find the
jelly right like or yeah or if you have
you can put your rhenium in it or
uranium that's right this isn't really
working which I imagine maybe uranium
you find in asteroids no is this the
Nintendo switch edition lol that's a
good one I have you heard that joke
before I haven't heard that one before
I've never heard that joke
this isn't really why shoot it I guess I
do yeah yeah you hit that and then at
all like wasn't working for a second if
I got a craft more ship launch sometimes
it's not working I feel like when I'm on
a shooting it
all right Rob I say we blow this planet
so we get out of here
once you get your copper maybe cool to
go to the system well like I think we're
gonna need to follow the tutorial so we
can get a dynamic resonator first so you
can get out of here
and I fine but let's find a better
planet to at least start our base on
fare let's do it
nope I didn't mean to do that oh my god
landing again you're probably gonna need
you to find I really don't want that be
the case guide I was trying to turn off
my tag dude killing it
okay I'll uh I'll go ahead you can get
up fine
everyone can watch me do this I'll watch
chat we did it I don't get the point
scavenge stuff build bases get great
weapons for what there's nothing to
fight everything seems dumb there's
there's the sentinels to fight and there
is a story so there's that to do but if
like you don't think the stories can
interest you then maybe it's not for you
that's not bad you know not everyone
needs to love every game
when will they release this on Amazon
Alexis I don't know being at Skyrim on
Alexa
he's more hydrogen
whoo I heard an Aimable sound like that
yeah they all sound the same still okay
let's play game what animal in Miami am
i imitating a very annoying deck see if
this is enough here the asteroids looks
so much better you'd be able to see it
from this half the planet dude blew it
down I see here like this is kind of
annoying having to do that instead
having to do like so many steps now in
order to take off I'm not entirely
what's the point of scavenging I don't
get it I its life scavenging who's the
life dude
he's fine anything cool I found some
silver found some gold no copper in
space yet though lots of titanium or no
try try to him try him I don't know okay
am I making the wrong thing am I really
this bad this is so new I'm making D
hydrogen jelly I shouldn't be doing that
I thought that's what you needed to make
is this Blade Runner does have that red
look like someone's to know what your
favorite blanket is I'm such an idiot
I don't like these steps Jake you you're
making it harder than it needs I know I
am I know exactly that all right I hate
this planet so much now
damn you're just giving me some of your
stuff too it reminds me of every Mars
film I've ever seen oh and if I can send
you some of my stuff I think you're too
far away or I want to say that all right
is this enough please be and uh yes
sorry everyone I'm playing a brand-new
game that feels like my ship is turned
into a giant scorpion is that normal
probably is their guns yes there are
guns we just don't have any yet because
we just started on Xbox is this I got a
gun right here or X oh yeah Rob does
haven't done just no ammo right or no
you do have ammo yeah I figured what you
need to make this is on the Xbox one
extra yeah this is xbox 1x
okay I'm ready to go are you sure
no yes
can two people ride in one ship now
unfortunately now but multiple people
can ride in a in a freighter right uh
yeah
though I don't know if this planet's any
good I there we're good baby
all right I'll find you where you at
I don't know home oh no I'm on a moons
no I see
I'm not liking this moon though Rob oh
really
yeah like it's just barren I don't see
anything oh I saw some copper there
though you can still mail a jetpack yes
someone asked that question yeah using a
little animation too for it yeah they
kind of owned it in a way what's wrong
with your planet this planet look at it
it's just barren we don't want a base
here do we
no all right I'm gonna check this bigger
one then what about our last planet the
first one was kind of cool it was cold
but it like had trees and stuff yeah oh
that's so sick oh you just warped out I
was gonna come meet you and those those
no I liked down to this one I love how
we can see your trail like it makes it
easy to like follow you oh wow this
experiment - wait no maybe not that
looks decent are you guys playing on
xbox because it's not out on pcs from
Josh no it is out on PC like right as we
started it came out on PC and he we're
gonna check out giant planets I don't
think there are a gas giant we're gonna
check it out ring yes sorry we're gonna
check out PC in a little bit or down the
road of the stream maybe in like an hour
from now there's a third verse person
view make a significant difference not
really but I kind of like it yeah it's
it's neat to go back and forth again
it's kind of tedious to do it like it
should just be a button yeah my opinion
but I can see you
all right this planet looks decent
enough are you seeing wildlife I kinda
wanna see it like a little animal taste
says that if we would play PC he can
swap in for me in here and I can play
out there you want to do something like
that okay yeah we can do that why don't
we do that sooner than later okay
just because we have far better saves
right yeah a little formation flying
here should we why don't we start
building a base at least get it set up
okay so you can at least see that yeah
it sounds good
like I'm surprised how well I don't know
like at least for Xbox like the netcode
and everything seems pretty tight or
like like yeah you're not glitching out
and haven't been since Josh wants a
dogfight oh yeah
where'd you go Jake
oh no my I'm dead already
I you died already oh I think it's
because I hit a tree and then you shot
me sorry
you'll come back alright are y'all
playing on high performance high visuals
this is my performance I think for me I
don't know a rob set for John what do
you mean oops
if you press Start and go to settings oh
go to get general options and there's
high quality and high performance
requires a restart as I'm running into
stuff oh man I have to repair my ship
sorry
where are you we're on the same planet
right oh I see you here
curse you I tried tagging you that's
what happens man
so those button prompts with exact same
that's why I landed accidentally the
last time watch I can't take off again
now okay
now you can't you're down 2-0 great
alright then should I see about take
coming in here yeah maybe maybe we just
do that we're just so we're just so far
along for anything like yeah we're much
and it'll be good on PC because then
people will see what it's like picking
up from a game you already have - yeah
did I lose anything when I died that's a
good question no I still have everything
it looks like oh wait no you do most
everything on my starship that's what
happens yeah oh so that's still saying
oh my god what is that
ant I don't think we can cut to mind no
he can't
which Idol whatta
very technology module I found a buried
treasure I really want to see this thing
your animal if I can get to you're too
far away I want to name it oh my god I
gotta get to you that animal is bonkers
oh my god don't move
keep an eye on that thing yeah we're
gonna switch in one second exactly what
the f is that is my sentiment - oh my
god you're on top of it yeah it keeps
knocking its head off dude you guys guys
see what Jake has discovered this is why
this game is amazing he's not sold I'm
gonna name it I'm gonna name it
something real cool because someone
asked me to name something you're so far
away well you killed me yeah well the
plus is that you have found a really
interesting animal and a buried treasure
I'm coming to you Oh Anna better bury
treasure that is so ridiculous
very very technology module
I don't know if you can destroy planets
nah you can't do that I think that's the
man by asking if I can be Goku all right
look what Jake has found oh is wait
probably get low oh you're here
no that's my ship you see the little
ships oh yeah yeah that's me yeah you
can see me moving around
we'll make it clear they can't wait to
see you rob this better be worth the
wait where is it oh shoot no way the
audience no way oh man never gonna but
now they're gonna think you were lying
oh there it is there's another one over
there
oh that's a different one that's a
bummer we don't see the same guy wait I
see that one though I see the one over
here maybe it's because it was like it
would have like disappeared by now for
you since you weren't there
look it's got a mohawk this thing's
cooler to be honest oh wait no right a
different one - you don't see this guy
either I maybe what you don't see the
same animals that's kind of interesting
oh you would do that we do see this guy
know I don't know we're different rate
of difference but we're different spot
though I don't even see look at that
all right I'm gonna swap out with Eric
okay and I'm gonna go set up I'm gonna
go make sure it's ready on PC I'm gonna
name this alright he's online we'll see
you online
indeed rename and upload that's fine
yeah we will hi everybody what's good
what's good Eric
let me turn do I need a save this worm
at all oh it disappeared I'm burning
some animal um do I need to save this
worm at all no you don't need to save it
there's like autosave off is I just shot
it whoops console off how's everyone's
doing great okay so we're gonna make the
swap now yeah give him one so we're
gonna we're gonna swap to Wow okay that
monitors not being responsive I'm gonna
let them watch you fight that thing oh
my god he's he's like oh he got you what
you get killed by waffles that's what
you get for naming him alright alright
do the switch switch I'm gonna be the
switch here guys sorry about that I will
be able to ask questions to Rob I won't
be able to answer them as much because I
don't really play no man sky however
it'll be easier for me to fire questions
off now that I'm here Wow there are a
lot of people others pause that please
how did that happen I don't know it does
that every time
where do I go about finding that I
always have to tell this time finding
[Music]
it's one of the hardest things to find
like hold alt tab that's it sick view go
to view got it nailed a music player I
don't even know those you might need to
agree to that you a thing
yep he died a horrible death waffles
waffles was not happy we are watching
our no man's sky PC save and then we'll
try to get synched up here with Jakob
Jakob geekiness
that's your shoutout how you guys doing
boom boom okay
house laughing alright so now we have a
save so we have some more stuff we got
money we got money we got saves he's
just gonna join you after the fact
hopefully take off your shirt no good
try whoa I don't know I won't do them
Chuckie a little bit that's fine
oh no this menu can chug its ironing out
all the kinks boo Torah says got my
first bug like hot pic keeps opening and
closing during the fighting or during
flight that sounds cool
show us first person please we did that
a wolf ohms f-4e ha ha ha good one is
that on ps4 yeah it's gonna be um it's a
it's not on all three platforms now
right should be yeah yeah Wow
chat is going real fast
this is taking a while where'd you get
that Hyrule print I want it leo I don't
know google it
I'm pretty sure you'll find it we got a
rapture one two like looks up gaming
posters Hyrule or something you'll find
it that's how we found it essentially
wow chat is going for quick dude look at
all these planets slowly coming our way
it's it's like we put on the slo-mo mode
will show you you can show first-person
in a little bit it's fine cheese is I
can't read all this so fast you know
show them nope can't show that is it out
already yes yes it is how are you guys
that's energy racing I'm good I've been
watching them play manly
I think Rob's excited Jake's excited for
the no - guy update so we'll see Wow
like like 20 lines literally just went
binding I could not read those fast
enough if you have questions as Jake and
Rob had mentioned earlier if you put the
word queue or another word the letter Q
in front of it or the word question in
front of it it'll help me kind of sort
out the questions so that I can ask them
to Rob that would be ideal this is
taking a while maybe it's like the first
time low because what what is this pcs
it's got a 1070 in it it's got a i7
should be able to run like any game
pretty much I wonder if it's like the
first time it's loading shaders buddy
epic shader so I don't know loading
times this long it depends on your rig
or I mean you think so I don't I mean
like I have no idea it's always put on
the SSD or not that's another thing to
think about but I mean like that would
be minimal so I I'm not sure this is the
first time we've loaded it up on PC so
we were playing on xbox 1x earlier glad
they're still working with a 3 FPS on
the loading screen
yeah well this matters less though
except it's really
oh my god it's funny like the music's
totally fine are you sure it's not still
downloading here I'm gonna go full
camera
quick alt-tab real quick it said ready
to play I know but that doesn't
necessarily mean like school like scroll
up I just want to see if anything else
is like dowling for anything okay no
it's not okay
we're we're in just we're in alt-tab
that's what we needed to do apparently
okay in it to win it well look at that
liquor in vats or wear it away array of
new features well the lab at bat all
right all right
it's run now it's running pretty well
got your ship
there's my ship that looks freaking ugly
wow dude hey man boxy it's okay man oh
my god the questions I'm so sorry I
would try to read is it cross-play no
it's not right not normally not really
yeah as it stands no concept of the game
srj I know could you just call it space
minecraft is that fair more so now -
yeah there's are like there any way to
kind of like like there are a lot of
things now where oh that ship is sick
sorry Pete okay Yuri Mario says I hate
boat guys joking on hero Academy and for
tonight you're a monster
I I can't believe you said that oh you
need your Xbox controller
yeah he would what a pleb doesn't play
on keyboard mouse yeah that's true he
doesn't want to fly off the keyboard
massive alien city's past evil brothers
I don't know we haven't explored enough
I don't I don't even know if that's a
thing is that a thing oh my god let's
get this ship it's way cooler what you
ask me it's alien cities is that a thing
no not really but you can make them now
Ian ask is it worth buying well we will
have a review eventually I think Justin
Clark's doing it with the next update so
you know depending on if you want to
wait for the review cool if not it's
hard for me to say if it's worth buying
cuz it's 50 bucks right yeah yeah on X
bar X lock this is interesting like
obsolete technologies new I wonder if
this is like old tech from the last
update like so
for those who were oh it's 20 slots less
20 slots less Josh is right
do you have it looks cooler I don't want
to do that damn god I'm Josh you got hey
Josh are you can play this game you
gonna play PC with Rob question why
should I join multiplayer apart from
exploring what is there to do well
technically I think maybe having a crew
or multiple ships will help you pirate
people right also I think that as Rob or
Jake had mentioned earlier by having you
know some buddies or companions with you
it makes the planets kind of feel less a
little less lonely you're kind of doing
stuff together the weird thing was that
in the last instance Jake and Rob we're
seeing kind of different animals on the
planet no I'm sorry not different
animals which is you guys weren't seeing
the same yeah even though you guys were
on the same planet hope that is
confirmed here yeah a lot of people
saying $25 on Green Man gaming so cool
check that out if you want to do it on
PC that that seems like a pretty fair
deal the update is huge and there's a
been doing a lot up until this point as
well so pretty cool stuff we're gonna
you know have a biggest change article
and video at some point just kind of
outlying some of the stuff that's in
here this is one of them if you missed
this earlier you have the ability now to
customize your character there's five
different races so much changes your NPC
colors you know of your armor and you
know you can do that as much as you want
there's like the gacks there's traveler
gangs gasp sorry yeah and so yeah
there's a bunch of stuff you can
customize there's pretty cool
are you guys on Steam or ps4 Swift we
have just swapped over to our steam or
PC save we were on Xbox one X first but
when we started the stream that's when
the PC update went live so now we're
checking out PC because Jake and Rob
have saves they're hoping to group up
here in a second they were playing
multiplayer xbox 1x earlier become a
ghek Kazuto don't worry Jake will become
a gag he loves gex and his like
are there romance options I don't
believe so no did they already meet
another player I mean we did in the
sense fire vine that it was at one of
our friends but we haven't met a random
if that's what you're asking
will you rescore the game I believe so
right with the review I mean like no
hospital it depends like the if the
score is the same then you know
obviously you know it's the same but if
it's if the update the next updates
better and has you know things that were
better than the previous version or
previous review then yeah it could
potentially be rescored but yeah it will
have a score on it can you customize
ships no I don't think you can yet but I
Shaun Murray has stated that there will
be weekly updates I would believe that
that's something down the road um that
can happen gama guy looks sick now
cheese storm says is this a new game in
some ways you could say it's a new game
in other ways you could say it's
technically an old game that just got a
huge massive update but it's also now
playable on xbox which it wasn't before
so in in certain ways yes yeah wow this
is so different conflict scanner Wow are
they Reeves a question you build your
own world can you fight in this game
what's the multiplayer like okay so can
you build your own world build your own
world you can build a base on a world
okay number two can you fight in this
game sure yes space and potentially on
the ground yes okay and three what's the
multiplayer like we haven't joined a
random I could join a random or you can
join a random yeah there that's an
option in the beginning of the game okay
cool it's like the first thing but you
know if you load up the game previously
it's like here are your saves you want
to play on creative survival or
permanent death or wherever before that
it's like join a game or sorry invite a
friend or join a random person like that
apparently there's a glitch with the
glass opening or the I guess the cockpit
will keep opening and closing I don't
know we'll see if we get that we haven't
gotten it ourselves akut food
how tall can you build the cap on
building is I think 20,000 like building
items units you want us okay
so pre to give you a frame of like how
massive that is before it was 2,000
that's like a potato I guess part it's
nice to see that the Deb didn't give up
on the game and kept working on it even
though they had so much pressure good
for them yeah it's it's awesome to see I
mean the funny thing is you guys got
back into it knowing that the next
update was coming but just checking out
all the way up to updates that they had
done previously and kind of got excited
again just from that and so the
perseverance definitely has paid off
it's it's cool to see them kind of
weather the storm obviously you know
there's a little bit more rough at the
beginning but you know we're here now so
so I just got a quest so here's a change
is that that was an npc I just got a
quest directly from him previously there
was like a guy I got like a merchant
that you'd go to and get secondary
quests so it look like I just like from
a random guy sitting there that's it's I
don't know that's that brings a little
more life into a world right like
opposed to just guys standing around
like I don't know you want to talk to
everyone I guess thanks RJ Reeves for
the nice words there someone said how
many total players per planet I don't
know yeah we haven't seen enough it's
hard to say we just know that for sure
you can multiplayer with 4 people not
sure if that means you can potentially
fight for before still not sure how
often you'll run into somebody Oh
someone just ran by I know it is it's
Jake really yeah it has to be right yeah
he's not a geek though he's not a GECK
yet Jake go be a geek
that's awkward
I don't know what that is bahasa 15 says
there's a new feature in this game
called League ma do you know if that's
true or did he troll me he's gonna Kobe
xre what you just asked him sorry
someone said there's a new feature
called big ma but I don't know if I
don't know they controlling me I'm just
gonna pass that off is this gonna be a
similar redemption story to read what
succeed or taking king or fanny packs
fanny packs haven't made a comeback um
that I know of
anyways it could be it's too smart I
think that there is things in the game
that are exciting I think just having a
multiplayer is is a huge plus so we'll
have to see where it kind of goes Oh
Mike McCarty also in on the action so we
remember seeing we might have a
three-person party so I think because of
that we'll see but you know just having
a party alone or like a party system or
a multiplayer type system like that
doesn't necessarily make a game fun
right like take try not to be mean here
but I guess take si of these for example
it's getting a new big update to next
week but people ran out of things to do
right and see if these even though like
the multiplayer aspect of it was fun so
we'll have to see what no Manas guy has
to offer in terms of like how complex it
gets you know how often are you able to
be a space pirate and things like that I
think I got trolled yeah you get trolled
yeah oh no the chats full of nope I'm
not
no stop it let's get back on topic I
hate you I hate you all I'm just kidding
I love you all alright now that we got
the troll out of the way can we can we
get back to civilization yeah bill Korea
asking how is the game hard to tell in
terms of like this later game part of it
because we just got onto PC we were
doing a lot of whoa early game stuff oh
look who it is in his stupid stupid ship
well I got a hit on his ship
what oh I like his ship more than yours
yours is so boxy he's got some
symmetrical he's he's got some abs
going on come on Mike go change your
character alright he's doing the spin
walk hate is love in the gaming world I
guess that's fair Oh Adam this is rad
all right you got me
let's get back on topic uh for real I
didn't add any more thing you can call
dude stop it stop it
you know what has that 15 I'm done no
more no more from you okay I almost got
me again but not that time all right
cannot customize ships yet hoping that
maybe it's the thing that comes down the
road hard to say spawning 95 it's not
actually $60 $50 on Xbox people are also
saying on PC it's $25 on Green Man
gaming are all the players in one world
yeah I don't know about that let's go to
my base okay are they following you is
did he turn into a gecko ready yes oh
you did okay we're using the old-school
chat aka
typing is the combat good I don't know I
saw you smoke Jake earlier with like no
problem but I was early on he he said he
had ran into something and then I like
finished all right here we go we're
going to do it again oh you gotta plug
in your controller now yeah you would
yeah you can switch me 21st a third
person
that's probably easier on PC than it was
on console is my guess do you think this
game has massively improved since launch
it's definitely improved I don't know
about massively I let Rob speak to that
I haven't played it
it has a massive they can't hear you
this feels like a completely different
game there you go
so yeah it's still very similar gonna
build a base in this livestream we're
gonna be married got a base built it's
really ugly but way to sell it I guess
the job done I'm done with this one chap
here all right oh this is fun hopefully
that works yep
all right no more of that then where
that uh you guys can stop using all that
weird stuff is there any music at all
yeah there's music oh what's going down
here why do I hear shooting oh look at
the rings on the planet
alright let's find my bass oh no it's my
bass not here well I just says is there
more unique explorable areas again hard
to say because they haven't played that
much of Mister is he trying to fight you
or something or is he fighting someone
he's my son but he's gonna dude I don't
know where my base is sweet I'm in a
different I think someone asked how did
it run on xbox 1x it ran well it looked
really good crippled says yes massively
better is their in-game voice chat I
don't know about that we haven't tested
uh-oh am I just not near oh you know it
might be I'm not I guess I forgot where
I was in my last save so I think I'm I'm
like in a different system cool so you
have build a new base then no I'm gonna
go back to it and dish these guys I
wonder if they can spawn on me again
good try off his bum and Nick is fine
good try though
good try man this is what happens when
you have more viewers you get you get a
couple trying to get get you yeah wow
that's really harsh let's see
where can we get the update notes
Rockstar they released official patch
notes office bum see you later trying it
twice no thanks wow that ship is cool
come on hips Ted don't don't tell him
his ship his cool his ship is a black
thank you it's cool I agree I nicknamed
it the dragon cool jet Lightning says
how does it run our regular base board
not sure I haven't tried it yet
on ps4 we've only played an Xbox one One
X and now PC if you guys don't stop
using that word
and trying to debate me I'm just gonna
kick a bunch of people which is totally
fine with me your base is most likely
deleted because of the reset is what
someone saying but I don't know if
that's I don't know I don't I don't know
about that let's find out I think I
think I'm in a different system but I
can find out cuz I'm getting quest
prompts that are saying go back to my
base okay we're playing on PC someone
else
Michael Levin controller is compatible
on PC because he was flying with the
controller play yeah well on the X
Thomas correct is that fair to say well
yeah no its way to play well on original
Xbox as well
multiplayer is real yes we are currently
with two other and you're right what no
base yeah cuz the reset right I didn't I
didn't I heard other people say
different things so I guess that it did
reset the base I didn't know that time
to make a base okay
oh that's a good one can you trade items
yeah you apparently you can okay oh geez
chats going too fast
Michael Davis says runs great on ps4 all
your base belongs to me that's correct
damn that's a bummer
while chat is really going fast
yeah it's okay half of its debates to be
honest dude Maya shooting sentinels in
there now they're like coming after
y'all
I'll show this wing optimized you feel
like I mean it's hard for you to tell
MBC because you just played but ya know
I feel I mean right now it feels great
as far as framerate and everything
someone asked is it worth playing now I
mean again I think that like there's a
lot of new stuff I haven't looked
through all the patch notes so it's hard
for me to tell you it was worth getting
back into I think that if you have some
friends that were playing no man's sky
or maybe thought about playing on this
guy maybe that'll get you guys to play
together Mike says they attack me in his
defense is this coming to switch no idea
how sensitive is the character
customization and ask Claire it's decent
it lets you pick between like five races
I think the five races had about ten
presets in terms of like how the face
looks and then the rest of its kind of
just like color coordinating your outfit
so it isn't detailed in like the sense
that you can change like how the eye
looks or how the face wit looks it's not
that detailed but there's options which
is pretty cool alright we're gonna go to
this planet Sandia says please address
for the viewers the fact that there is
no multiplayer unless you are in a party
well we don't know that for sure because
you got to be able to fight other people
because they showed that right in the as
a space pirate so here's the thing too
is like yesterday Sean Murray tweeted
out like an atlas map where if you were
to find what's called a portal in the
game it gives you glyphs like kind of
images that determine your location in
the excuse-me galaxy on this map was
also like hubs were like I look like
clans have like picked areas where they
are gonna reside like systems so what
I'm getting at is like you might have to
take an approach of looking at this
atlas map if you want to find people in
game then that's one way of doing it
otherwise we haven't tested out but
there is a join random player option
that to me just means just like you just
pop in wherever someone is and you
I don't know so you can potentially see
random people you might just have to try
to find them yeah let's see there's
still a lot of that photo boats pretty
cool too
oh man it's not letting me show me I do
what's your new favorite thing about the
update so far well do multiplayer it's
really cool seeing people like Jake
playing with you and like - now Tyler
you got a boon some people yeah because
people like there's a lot of people that
keep trying to bait me into saying two
different things and I'm like really not
into that so let's see and now there are
rings around planets okay so
sandhya sets from the patch notes while
wandering the galaxy solo continue to
experience chance encounters with
strange floating orbs oh [ __ ] what space
pirates which I attack them like actual
space but they're scanning my ship well
I hope you have help they found some
gravity Mobile's
they ain't getting my balls okay don't
let him have him
Battle Royale question mark now can you
land on asteroids well let him focus
right now
would you say your ship is a pretty
strong battle class mine's more of a
like a transport mining ship oh wow
might kill destroyed a 92 nice go to the
ring yeah I was trying to let's see
your party is us up to four whoa you
didn't answer my question can you land
on that thing on asteroid I don't think
so
is there void I don't not in game I
don't think so okay I don't know yeah
I've been dreary I know I'm sorry thanks
for sticking around though Juno berries
thank you for the kind words earlier
what has changed about freighters as far
as I know could you I don't we send
Raiders out without know so okay so
there's like yeah the new thing is
apparently there's like a fleet command
where you can have like a freighter
enough to like 6d other ships so you
like create a fleet and send them a a
send them out to go do it I think maybe
mine I'm not quite sure
okay Garda James questions have you
tried baseball they're having you know
update I can't seem to create a base
only shows me options to create the XO
base units will save welcome do it pets
patch notes suggest you can build
anywhere now so we're gonna try that
right now man
I'm trying to read is arranged for both
which gain spot and YouTube thanks
everyone for tuning in if you didn't
know we're always live not always we're
live every day Monday to Friday that's
not even every day I got to rework this
pitch doing that hey guys just so you
know gates out live Monday to Friday
11:30 come hang out with us we play new
updates we play new games preview games
and get them early play games that have
like weekly updates maybe no man's sky
becomes one of those things depending on
what those weekly updates are you know
fortnight challenges yep I know there's
some people that didn't weren't too
happy about 49 in the chat but hey for
tonight's thing happy birthday for
tonight actually
and yeah so subscribe if you haven't
because that will help notify you guys
if when we go live also for when we make
cool features Joey's show potato mode
pretty fun stuff if you haven't seen it
Jake's has a new show coming up this
weekend nostalgia trip that'll be
another fun one to check out I know John
Luke will start getting back to the
history of Ziff you if you guys are into
that I'm just kind of showing guys you
know game franchises where they started
how they got to like where they're at
now I feel like I'm missing some grave
hoppers Rob and Mike new show on
Thursdays 2 p.m. Pacific where they
pretty much add permadeath to every game
it's pretty intense somehow I'm still
mad at Mike if you guys didn't know he
watch episode few and you'll know it's
etude
this lands pretty cool let's let's make
it home let's see what it's got it's got
a cool ring on it alright so what we
need to do is you can do not build
underwater you got it why you can have
underwater bases now shout out to
imagine dragon sure for the new song or
anything like that dude this game is
sick
sorry oh it's raining now I like it
alright uh Rob's gonna attempt to build
hopefully try to start the base GA kae
yeah see so that's what the person in
chat was saying it was only laying them
do save pods and EXO buildings hmm JKL
oh we are gonna review the game oh look
again they do move in herds
so it's possible you know like the the
rating could change but it's also
possible that the changing the rating
doesn't change so stay tuned again spot
calm in the coming days like off-screen
lying
you know anybody know the size of the
game the update was like six to seven
gigs on PC but I don't know about the
actual full game size you are in the
rings okay yeah do you know I think
that's Mike one of those guys that shot
your ship anyways he's had I don't know
okay so I don't know if I can build but
I can try something so previously you're
now supposed to be able to build
anywhere you want but previously you had
it don't shoot my ship you had to find
like a a habitable base so let's see if
we can start there maybe that's that'll
do it it won't even let me pick oh here
we go
I feel like it's different so much
different now okay I need nanotubes and
metal plating
and make any of these nanotubes and
middle plating so I'm gonna need carbon
and yeah okay
now this is where the fun begins all
right don't mind us while we're firing
can you have multiple faces and if so
can you teleport between them Astra yeah
yeah yes the answer is yes okay game
audio just go down or you turn it down I
turned it down
okay I'll return your backup he just
says there's a smidge loud just now oh
no - guys this place exploration game
not TPS or FPS the shooter aspect is
only to mine and defend yourself it is
not your type of game if that's not your
type of game just move on it's certainly
good exploration game down yeah yeah
fair let's see
for people saying build a base computer
build a base computer is that a thing I
don't know man this is a whole new game
I'm trying you know face computer to
build that's why I spilled the base
computer thank you all right it can't be
troll there was like 15 people that said
the same thing we'll find a different op
there it is dude thanks guys okay yeah
good thank you chat Thank You chat
that's why we love you metal okay how do
I make chromatic you just tell those
those two guys that you have with you to
drop some metal yeah I could hey if you
guys on delay I know you'll you'll see
this but we're trying and Kay bet
there's so many there's so many chats
that I'm doing my best I appreciate it
though don't worry we'll see it also
there is delay I will
so there's functionality in YouTube that
we can potentially interact better with
the chat but that could potentially
lower the quality of the vaad it's
something I want to test around with but
it might be worth it so look to that in
the future so that we can have more
real-time conversation etc I don't know
how to make where's Jay man he is not he
is outside right now I'm fake Jake right
now
fake Jake okay I don't know what are you
trying to do I'm trying to make
chromatic metal but I don't think I have
the blueprints to do it well then it
doesn't sound like you can build sir
let's try this again basic computer yeah
okay oh here it is for in a refiner so I
need copper cadmium and Emeril and in
the indium f that's a weight sweet okay
let's let's see if we can do it blame
fake Jake for what I did nothing let's
do this someone wanted you to zoom out
on the map just all the way to show
scale I don't know if I can do that here
I have no problem I can do it in space
yeah do that later question what happens
to mats and valuables that were stored
in my old base that's a good question I
think you're I think you're effed Wow
don't say that we don't know that for
sure oh hi Tyler are you gonna be good
this time build the portable refiner
first yeah okay I'll do that we're still
gonna need whoo I want to do some more
interesting for the sake that's a good
question now let's ground I'm not sure
if you choose a race can you
automatically understand your chosen
races language I don't know is a good
question what the hell is this look
office bum it has a legitimate question
instead of trying to debate me are they
still going to be doing any big content
updates after this one or is it gonna be
small incremental bug fixes and tiny
stuff they said weekly updates but we
don't know the scale or scope of that
there could be events like it's possible
but yeah no one really quite knows
what's up ethical pick so how are you
doing okay so let's see who says you
need to build a scanner we're playing on
PC right now Mike a drive this game is
so different now can you still play a
first-person yes yeah I can do that
right now to build the base computer you
need to build a refinery first and
convert a copper to that metal yeah so
happy that people saw that yeah we were
playing on Xbox one
not anymore we were playing on PC now
okay
I Ryan so right now I'm doing buried
treasure this is something that's new
okay that was a guy role excited Ryan
just so you know Ryan is our one of our
mods in chat I'm gonna start getting
Pete rid of people that are either being
disrespectful or trying to bait me into
saying stupid stuff so that is out there
just want you guys to know I just want
this chat to be more about no man's sky
questions you know criticisms chat
whatever damn the storm is intense
stop getting salty over a joke it's not
necessarily about that it's just
annoying to have people do that kind of
stuff so I actually want to build a
community and a chat that you know wants
to hang out together and not be deterred
by people being jerks about it so that
will be my prerogative today how do you
start building a base well we need a
base computer which we can't make yet
but we're working on it
so I need to make a refinery first
savage ducky yes you can use a
controller on PC a flux I can't tell you
if it's good or bad yet I think it's too
early to tell but we'll have a review on
gamespot calm eventually once we you
know spend enough time on it so look
back for that okay I should be able to
make this now dig a hole and hide from
the weather we kind of did that I just
did it yep chat is definitely becoming
senders to ask dynamic weather yeah it's
like you just kind of just saw it like I
just popped it even the storms look
amazing says I am
how do you change the POV for PC its
it's gonna be X and then you carry over
to utilities and then you bring that
down to toggle camera views Sam Kimpton
it's got 1070 i7 I forget which model i7
and I think it has 32 gigs of RAM that's
basically the most important stuff you
need to know
I forget which I 7 is though so sorry
let's play NACA sucks what motor you are
do you know this is normal ok how do you
start a session with a friend walking
through it please zero meadow you
basically have an option to play with a
friend at the beginning and that's kind
of how you do it right and then you
through snag them J like Jake just found
a way by I mean I would assume just
joined game like it's it's easy like we
could even look at settings because I
bet there's an option to be like opt out
of letting people join your game
probably options I've seen anything be
sharing and I could that could be it
someone said there's an option to like
opt out of having people back to options
real quick to just look at networking
boy so just curious oh sure oh that
sounds already like oh there we go what
was that [ __ ] sorry there it is ok so
it's just like and you can invite from
there yeah interesting to see that
there's like 16 slots there don't know
if that means anything there yeah ok
change or salute as Jacob day you need
to get to a space station yeah and then
you're able to but are you were able to
actually change your suit it's just
colored no no you're no you should
oh yeah straight up there's like there
are many many options and like variants
to like there's like five races and then
subsequent like types you can swap in
and out it's quote Ellie rocks not sure
if there's local multiplayer that's
gonna be added that I know of also you
can use all caps here and there but try
not to spam if you guys put a question
in front of your question it helps me
find it or queue in front of it okay so
we're looking for
Jasper there's probably no battle royale
coming anytime soon nor are they gonna
add a John wick skin but there's your
question 100% kick anyone who isn't
respectful people these days are used to
being entitled disrespectful teaching
yep I agree mighty - I mean even office
bum and I hopefully he changes his tune
came back and asked the actually a good
question instead of trying to bait me
into saying some terrible things to try
to like get me fired essentially is too
intense I think we should get off of it
okay you do you I'm just reading chat
yeah you can change your race there's
five races that you can pick from
question will you turn into a cake no
that's Jake's role how do you start
based we need a base builder to start
and then we need other stuff we don't
have all the materials right now to make
one unfortunately can you build a base
in space I don't think so can you tear
form a planet
no you can kind of build a base like a
planet I don't know no I don't think so
Kay sorry you can kind of build a base
in space easy you can buy a freighter
and then you can like that has yet to be
seen yet but on a freighter you can then
like customize it's kind of like a
miniature base in a way we're looking
like ad rooms and storage and terminals
and stuff Alex Brown husband full is the
game on xbox 1x it looked pretty really
really good I think it looks great
can you crash your ship I know you can't
crank a mitt you can't crash land but it
can explode and then you just get a new
one and it becomes damaged then the
update is for free right yet if you
hadn't previously yeah cross play no
unfortunately not that we know at least
not yet just bought this on ps4 next
looks like it finally made it good yeah
I mean that's the hope I mean one of the
bigger things for us right now at least
in the office is that some of the people
that you know played no mask I to start
but that kind of fell off now they kind
of have a reason and just at least as a
starting point just the fact that they
can play together
and we'll see where it goes from there
right like there's a lot of stuff in the
update to check out and as we'll see how
deep it is you know
it still needs you still need stuff you
know that compels you to play outside of
just playing with your friends
can you change your race multiple times
ask tomboy yeah yes you can change it as
much as you want you're not locked into
one you just have to go to a space
station to do that though and there's no
like currency or anything like that it's
free yep Alex and drove it on drove it
17 and asked there was a mention of
question objectives how are they have
you done any of that yeah I know you got
like one you kind of like Questor thing
from the space station right yeah it's
basically the same in a way but I want
to say that you can get two quests more
easily like here is my quest right so on
the base I just talked to this dude and
he gave me this quest why don't you want
to just do that sure let's do it okay
radar the planetary harvester and steal
data let's try to do that so this was
this an NPC that earlier that was on a
space station he just like hey I was
talking he's like you want to do this
quest I'm gonna do this for me like a
mission was like I'm still in the update
is out on ps4 yes okay MPC and console
players play together no not as of right
now are you using a ps4 Pro no we're
currently playing on PC actually a co-op
question we're yeah we're actually co-op
or we're party together with Mike and
Jake who are playing from outside in the
video editing area Mike will actually be
back on another stream or on a stream
today at 2 o'clock we're gonna play
Ghost Recon wildlands is new update
which has a Rainbow six siege crossover
as well as a new permadeath mode
damn it's 1 p.m. yep that you have about
30 minutes give or take is there an
actual story now I mean there was a
story from the first game I don't know
if they've changed anything
they added so like the last update which
was crazy I think it was like last
August so almost a year ago they added
like a quest a main quest line which is
a story and it's it's pretty cool it
like brings mystery and everything like
I liked it
our freighter is the only way you have
more than one percent ownership yes yes
and that we know right now right yeah
they may add that later you know yeah
question do predatory creatures come out
and I don't know any way to make in-game
money quick I think you just have to
find a planet that has something rare
you want yeah you want to find two
things basically is like find a planet
with something plentiful make a base
there and then you would want to find a
system by chance a system that will give
you a lot of money for said resource so
like there's a there's an aspect of
trading in this game is interesting is
there more combat and enemies or do you
still kind of just do is there more of
like what it was before what's the
question is there more combat in enemies
now or is it kind of similar to what it
was before like you're not fighting that
much right or at least not the planets
that I've seen you go on yeah it depends
a lot on like the system right like you
can have like a conflict system where
like Oh see this is so annoying it auto
lands when I'm trying to tag it ok yeah
like you can get raided by pirates you
can like like it's more unexpected I
mean you could find trouble I want to
say but it's you know this game is very
much about procedural generation of like
animals to combat so like a whole bunch
of stuff so do you know oh we've never
been in a freighter yet but someone asks
can you steer the freighter you know
what we can do is I could opt out of
this and say sorry guys later and do a
creative mode and then I can get afraid
or immediately then we can look at that
do you want to try to jump around to
many things so I should just pick one
because literally
fair you're running out of time I know
that's what I'm saying I know but that's
what I'm saying like you should do this
is it too late to get into no man's sky
no I don't think so I think of anything
if you had thought about it before it's
probably no better time to get back into
it
that now neon cinema the multiplayer is
compelling for them as just like the
first as one of the major parts of the
next update but they still haven't
played enough for me to say like hey
play this game because what was that oh
my god what the hell is that
we got mechs now oh my god yo boys we
need help
let's just do the mission and get out of
here maybe Jake Mike oh all right
oh my god he's every fighter for
chromatic metal okay got it
question you said we can build a base
ten times bigger well you said it was
2000 previously in that twenty thousand
right right so I don't know if that's
literally ten times bigger but just
simple math says it is but you know
having actually built one so can't tell
you this this feels this feels like a
quest that might be our sport co-op and
MMO aspects I don't know if there aren't
animo aspects but uh we can show you
more co-op once these guys arrive to
help us
they Jake did I think he's dead oh he's
in here now you can turn this off oh
he's doing it oh he's a champ
nice move have you failed you guys fail
or said you failed he's using it
as mike is probably a fight like all
that stuff alright oops
is this a mustard planet kind of
okay cool so that was basically it
I just took another stream and they just
found biological monsters something like
aliens oh my god I don't know what that
means I don't know what that means
either I just read it dad I do not know
about the ship mdj you can buy a
freighter and drive it yeah if you have
a lot of money if you help a freighter
out in the battle the captain will give
you the freighter for free in this new
updated normal mode oh so that's how you
update is there a player link oh that
was a good question someone asked me
about tether you're not what you're not
tethered to where the rest of your party
is so like you if if they're exploring
on one part of the map you can still
explore on the other side of the map
right and then yeah I need you all right
right so there's no tethering or
anything like that raindrop happens
definitely in this game it will happen
have you found any abandoned systems I
don't know that means banned 'end and
they're all Kabaddi and didn't okay X
pace Rx says no you can't steer fly
freighters you can only call them to
your location
how do you switch the third-person view
on PC you can't find the key for that X
don't give it to you that MEC was an
enemy it stopped here the ground
Sentinel SiC top tier question do you
recommend restarting the game after the
next update because of the significant
changes say that again
would you recommend restarting the game
yeah me on that now that mazes uh I
don't know would you continue it your
game depends on how far you in your how
far you're in like how the clouds look
good guys how do I get back to my old
base from what we heard from chat
you might your old base might have been
like reset because of the update now I'm
not a hundred percent sure on that so
don't quote me on that but we could not
find Rob's base so I think I think they
all got wiped I think I want to say that
there's abandoned space stations okay
I'm trying to like let my Sentinel
activity oh ok so there was some kind of
abandoned station and there were eggs he
shot the eggs and monsters came out of
it it was really freaky the AI was not
that bad
oh my god damn that's pretty crazy
that's crazy
I just want these guys should we should
we do a different mode in what in the
next 15 minutes it's up to you I'm just
reading questions would you say your
sense of wonder is invigorated with this
update do you want to explore again we
Wyatt I'm sorry you say that again
that's like I'm losing it yeah that's
why we're gonna end the stream in 15
minutes he's losing it would you say
your sense of wonder is invigorated
again like are you excited again yeah
yeah I'm sorry Florian yeah okay do you
want to explore again yeah yeah go yes
okay
is this effing fleet combat I don't
think we did any of that there but yeah
oh this was someone was saying look at
this is that glitch oh yeah yeah we're
just exploring that didn't happen on
xbox though huh
no all right you won't see the freighter
oh look at those beasts wait you have
one yeah dude that was sick that was
tight that was tight let's do that again
so if you do find an abandoned station
Rob maybe try shooting some eggs cuz
that's pretty cool Ryan I'm not sure
let's try that again because I was sick
are you ready for it does anyone know
how to build a fleet I have the same
ship I'd like to know if you can name
planets I mean should be able to as long
as they're unexplored discovered right
you can name a plane as long as it's
never been found before correct yeah
okay so this is my this is my capital
ship yes they're still grinding for sure
fleet named exploration game as I mean
mentioned all right so let's take a
question do you need to finish the intro
and get your ship fixed before you can
play with a friend or can we both try to
fix our ships together you can bolts fix
your ships together that's how we did it
today this morning on xbox you can
immediately join ok let's see do you
guys think they'll make the multiplayer
bigger ah I don't know I mean it's four
players for now watse apparently we are
super passive-aggressive sorry if I'm
coming off that way maybe not enough
coffee thanks for tuning in
can you cultivate different space drugs
I don't know don't think so
he's way too jacked up for this game
he's excited said next day has finally
come
he's the worst multitasker ever hey I
think men in general are bad at
multitasking
I'm terrible at it like it's hot all
this I'm fighting the urge to do
different things because it's like the
first time you trying to show everything
yeah there's a bunch of different stuff
we could do and he's just I think that
part of it too is like he probably
hasn't seen the freighter come in like
that you know so give him give him a
little bit it's like he's like the n64
kid for Christmas no I'm not I call so
all these guys now you guys are cool
thanks Brian stone appreciate it fleet
room okay so let's see if we make that
real quick as pvp only with your team or
with other players we haven't seen any
other players at Gregory ruff so if
we've PvP we've Burton when she took out
ourselves whoa I haven't played puppy
funny clips so I I can't share my
opinion Robb's kind of just like early
back into it he's excited though he's
juiced again to play multiplayers
obviously exciting and yeah that's all I
can really say for right now
so this all comes with a base game and
do you think it's worth it I'm not
reviewing the game so I I mean it's hard
for me to say I think if you're
interested in no man's sky previously
now is probably one of the best times
again to the game if you were interested
obviously having some friends that might
play with you is good just because that
might also help kind of spark your
interest or continue your interest and
yeah I think some people in chat
mentioned it was like twenty five twenty
eight dollars on Green Man gaming for PC
it's fifty dollars on Xbox so I would
assume P a sports bar the same price but
can't say that for certain
this is neat what was the mode select
about there's different modes you can
pick we're on normal there's what create
no this missus creative oh this is how
I'm able to get into a freighter because
the creative mode just wipes away any
idea of currency or money so you can
just get awesome that okay sorry I
thought you're selling your account I
was like dude cool I just think I still
need to hire someone we don't have much
time do it now we get some insight yeah
sometime you we could go over but yeah
I just logged in and everything is
different what's up with all the
materials and I'm confused how it works
out yeah so you're basically like as
Mike and Jake had I think said this
earlier it's like almost like playing a
new game
in some ways cuz like you're kind of
relearning a lot of the elements that as
you mentioned have kind of been changed
around so yeah yeah I don't really know
how to make a fleet I think this might
take too much time yeah that's scary
someone said Jess
Jesper said I was just flying towards
the space station using pulse engine and
a frigate spawned on or spawned inside
of me and I was stuck and couldn't get
out so I deload my last save I'm sure
there's gonna be some bugs
they'll be fixed yeah I need to I need a
terminal takes about an hour to get used
to the new layout
oh that's cool so I can warp ooh all
right let's just warp to any of these
whoa so like if you don't want to do the
grind you could kind of just do this
right and just warp far quicker Kent he
wasn't afraid or just now yeah he's in
creative mode so that's why he was able
to get get that freighter warp
any comparison to elite dangerous at
this point that's right there's some
there's some comparison I don't know I
mean you can get out of your ship
so that's cooler mentally dangerous
meifa not sure if they how much
optimization they've done for those
people that may have computers that
aren't as beefy gillo Gilly Gilly oh
sorry if I butchered your name I think
we're both are in the bay area you're
born here right yeah yeah oh yeah whoa
this there's so much to this now so
here's like some of the fleet stuff oh
my god I'm way over my head but learning
you're evolving so is I believe this is
my freighter so I can manage this
there's like stats and stuff do you need
to still learn languages like before
yeah question can you spend the entire
game on one planet system I mean you
could if you really wanted to but you
probably get pretty boring at some point
because you're seeing the same stuff I
would assume right we want to get out
there and explore different planets
different systems absolutely
okay so now it's telling me actually
directing me over here to do it
a fleet command room Andre says you have
to go to a space station to find you a
specialist yeah I know that much that's
what I was thinking but I don't know
sometimes this game has like weird
structure as far as like what's trying
to tell you to do I don't know it says
now I could i can build a fleet command
room wow you can really customize this
whole area that's really cool except
that's still it's floating fleet command
room not sure ask daily about why the
pre-order Xbox are more than showing up
but I'm sure there's if it's a common
bug it'll be fixed apologies of your
experience
don't know like I'm wasting time I don't
know how to do this we're about ready to
wrap up anyway right yeah I mean is
there anything else you want to show um
[Music]
did you try landing on one more question
this is a completely different safe I
know that I did finish it yeah no I
didn't because I I was under attack and
I just yeah I did not finish it but I it
would have been very easy to finish if I
just got back to the space station I
would have cashed in whatever was Jay
Solomon we were actually partying up
just now but Rob wouldn't to creative
mode to show off the freighter
so yeah let's go is Space Station so
here it is let's rock the fleet actually
we do this just tell me more
oh maybe it's an area fleet command room
I do this one more time sure that's how
you want to spend your 10 minutes I know
everything's a blur now well haven't all
that excitement and enthusiasm are your
derp on the option menu so maybe try
that how do you get a frigate or Freight
someone said that if you save a freight
that's being under attack the captain
will give you a free Freight that's a
normal mode you can also buy a freight
but it's pretty expensive so
Cody he'll probably won't show character
customization again today but if you
scroll back DVR and in back in time they
showed it in the beginning of the stream
and also a little bit we did their color
times maybe happening we have some
gameplay up on our site that it has that
first it should be up yeah
like I don't see it's saying a command
room but I don't a large freighter room
in between the bridge
is the shooting fight in this game I
think it's fine that's not really bad
things about yeah is that the bridge
right there Bridge and the hangar so is
that the bridge and then that was the
hangar that you're just that yeah I mean
this is it but it says in between no
yeah which is like right here I guess
yeah so it doesn't mean like right just
a room right here
enjoy your dinner Clos the command room
can't be places it can't be places I
don't know no one knows how to place the
command room is maybe what are you
saying
I like I'm expecting it to be a terminal
which would be like here but there's no
[Music]
like command have you looking all
technology options technology options I
don't know it's just something else
sautéed that probably didn't help you
ooh what see I can do it again as long
as someone was asking I just do it show
I like a little bit of it look at you
Johnny Five is alive yeah that's kind of
like Johnny Five um see what else
did that
storage no no control room isn't there
is what rub tub does yeah I don't know
bummer
is there anything else let's go laying
on a plant one more planet and another
do it get the load another save then
I don't know he unplugged
Wow that is annoying whoa
Eli says we're trying to build it too
and we can't find it copy that thank you
for that appreciate y'all yeah okay I
think someone was saying that the
options not there that's what rub what I
what I think is that like part of the
things with the base building is a ye to
hire first like an overseer of the
construction I'm like a construction
terminal first so maybe that's like the
first step you need to do before you can
get that far anyways
what exactly is happening we were just
in a freighter trying to mess around in
that now we're just gonna land on one
more planet here to end the stream
we'll play multiplayer earlier with Jake
and Mike kind of did one mission
together probably should have showed
that more to be honest now that I think
about it just multiplayer in general
playing together but all good too many
things to show on the update so trying
to hit as many things as we can I don't
know why I looked at that that almost
made me sick so apparently it's a bug it
appears in normal mode but not in
creative mode Oh Ricky says which would
just kind of make sense as to why you
might not have seen it
30k players on Steam it's pretty good
whoops whoops looks hella better though
yeah a little well via cold someone said
there's like three vehicles is that true
yeah nope why it's doing that
oh there it is so we're currently in
creative mode correct right so you again
there's your as you know I'm limited
with blueprints and everything so now I
can
buggies are pretty fun
should have done a race there are there
are races there car races yeah oh there
are cars yeah that's what they said so
you can like make a race I think and
upload it to like Steam Workshop sore
that's however things have fun with the
update valid ox fly to finish of things
we will hi John how are you doing are
there guns yes our guns okay I'm gonna
have to cop this all right dude I'm into
it call it yeah then we should call it
there uh all right thanks everyone for
tuning in thanks Rob for playing and
Jake as well earlier that was just kind
of like a brief kind of playthrough of
some multiplayer and just a bunch of
different aspects of the the update
there's more that we didn't explore talk
about Rob's excited give me give me some
thoughts Rob there's so much to do I'm
like there's a lot to take in but so far
I think Peter Browns the best it's
glorious I'm into it there's a lot going
on nice yeah the multiplayer is really
neat like now we didn't get a chance to
do it but like building a base and
having I don't know something like
communal right something that we can
chip away at and take a look outside I
don't know it's cool it's cool to play
and it was working fairly well like as
far as people joining in and out like
it's we did PC and Xbox both like worked
pretty damn well which is great I think
so far this is this is really great I
think it's it's so much better than what
was that launch and you know some
hiccups here with like the cockpit you
know there that's a given but yeah but
nothing to game breaking right now
obviously some people are gonna be more
upset about you know some of those
things but hey they're gonna update it
you know weekly as you mentioned we'll
see what that what those updates have
you know if they're big enough maybe you
and Jake get back in here or you and
Peter get back in here to do some of
that stuff but I hope so come back in
half an hour less than half an hour
we're gonna be streaming again Erin and
Mike are gonna play Ghost Recon
wildlands is new update that has a
rainbow 6 siege crossover mission
and has a new mode called ghost mode
which introduces permadeath I heard that
might even get into great hoppers which
is the show you and Mike have just
started
it'll be week three this Thursday so
come back in half an hour and then if
not make sure you hit that sub button so
that you guys are informed for the next
time when you guys do no man's sky next
update and or whenever we go live which
is every day at 11 for GameSpot excuse
me daily where we do the news in you
know 15 minutes 30 minutes or less and
then gamespot live where we play new
games new updates weekly updated stuff
previews etc like that and yeah that's
all I have for now I know we'll see
hopefully some of you act 2 o'clock
which is in about half an hour
thanks again Rob thank you who's up
who's